i don't remember where it was it might
have been a country that said they were
going to make editing your photos
illegal
right i can't remember where that's
happening but um i've seen i've seen the
impact of social media on my cousins i
have a couple of
teenage girl cousins and it's rough
because every single person that they
follow edits their photos in ways that
humans can't really look
yeah
they feel ugly yeah yeah but you know
what's so funny these people have
plastic surgery so they've had plastic
surgery and then they're editing their
photos on top of plastic surgery
so it it absolutely is the case
because you feel like well what's wrong
with me
all these people look flawless shouldn't
i look that way because obviously
there's a certain
you know worship that we have for our
you know for you know the people we look
up to
you know it's you know it's in all
fields and it's in all ages you know
maybe a younger person looks up to
excuse me a um
you know
a famous person you know i look up to my
you know my heroes in my in my
professional world you know the people
that are the giants and the people that
i learned from you know who made a lot
of advances in my field so we all look
up to people but the generation
definitely looks up to people who are
more beautiful and more you know
archetypal or you know
or are the best in terms of their
appearance and it's really unfortunate
but everybody
seems to manipulate their their images
and it's so funny because you look at
these magazines sometimes and they
always have like little arrows showing
where you can see like the edges of a
photo looking all like you know
janky and like
you know the person sitting there and
their waist looks this thin but then you
see like the bricks like having a
distorted pattern around them because
they just crush the pixels
so it's like sometimes it's really goofy
and obvious
but again
you know getting bombarded with that
imagery over and over again really wears
away your brain and makes you feel
inadequate
hmm
yes bit of a pickle
it's definitely a bit of a picture yeah
but it's a pickle but i think it's a
pickle that can be solved
you know because once these companies
are held accountable for their behavior
they will change their behavior because
if you can imagine the financial
downside of a class action lawsuit of
tens of thousands of families who had
children who wound up with mental
illness or suicide it would be in the
number of trillions of dollars
but the thing is is that right now there
is no repercussions
they can do whatever they want whenever
they want and there's nothing you can
say about it
so once that happens i think that
they'll be more responsible with what
they do
and they can even enact policies where
can you know come on we have such
technology
they should have the ability to use
technology to make sure that those kind
of images are not allowed to be posted
like that's a possibility why should
that be allowed
you know if we know it's causing
significant pervasive public mental
health problems which it does
why don't we hold people accountable to
make it different
we should
that's a very good idea
that's a that's a very good idea i don't
know why
that wouldn't have been i guess
everything is so new social media is so
new it hasn't been along around and long
enough for people to
yeah but i think that the reason why is
at the end of the day is that all of
these companies all they really want
they're not concerned with ethics they
want more eyes more volume more clicks
you know and more ability to then
because of the volume of traffic be able
to sell advertising it is a business
so if a altered image gets more
attention than an unholded image
they prefer the altered image
right
because if it's going to get more views
and clicks
then that means more revenue and that's
really what they are at the end of the
day they're for-profit companies they're
publicly traded and they're motivated by
profit like all corporations are but
when it has pervasive mental health
you know complications for us as a
society i think that we need to take a
step back and hold people accountable
for their behavior that's and this is
like getting way off target from what
plastic surgery is
but i you know because of what i do for
a living i see how devastating it can be
over long term to people young and old
do you have people come in that show you
pictures of clearly altered faces
and say i want this absolutely
so especially younger patients they come
in with their iphone and they have like
a file of screenshots
of people whose appearance they covet
i like this nose i like my lips this way
i want this like this and this like that
and obviously you can't transplant those
things on patients so you need to be
educated and you have to go over with
them what's possible what the
limitations are because not every nose
and every face can just be made into
something
you know you can get parts of things it
has to do with what you start with
um it's not like you can just plug
things on it's not plugging chug it
doesn't work that way
but it is very very common for people to
show up with that kind of that kind of
information
to a consultation
do you have advice for people who are
potentially interested in this on how to
avoid bad surgeons
yeah i mean i think that you know
you know where we live we live in a
modern era and people have access to
information
so it's very i think it's pretty easy i
mean people do deep dives and everything
right people are gonna buy a vacuum
cleaner when they go online and they
read about the vacuum cleaner they look
and read about people's online reviews
and what their experience is like with
it
you know you can get a lot of
information out there
so i think that's one of the first
places to start
is by doing that kind of deep dive and
research into people
you know people have different expertise
if you want a rhinoplasty and you know
you go to a doctor you see that mostly
what he does is breast augmentation is
probably not a good idea but you know
this is the kind of information that you
can get
by just spending some time
and then after you do that
um you should you know see a number of
doctors and i always say this you should
go with your gut because
you know sometimes you can be
intimidated we're in a situation where
somebody's supposed to be you know a
very you know well-known or professional
person um and it can be difficult
because you're like well this person's
supposed to be so great i really should
have them do it but you really need to
listen to your internal compass
because you know beyond you know doing
your deep dive
not every
you know doctor is going to be the right
fit for you
and obviously the doctor just doesn't
have to be a good technician but they
need to be a good person because they
need to see you through the recovery
phase of your surgery and be able to
address concerns as they as they arise
and if somebody seems to be short
arrogant you know doesn't want to answer
your questions or for just some reason
you guys don't get along
this is like a marriage
you know you know you're you're you're
this is like going it's almost like
speed dating like you know you get a
sense in your gut right away like this
isn't going to work
it's not going to be any better after a
surgical treatment so i think it's
important to listen to your instincts as
well
but you know obviously referrals from
other doctors referrals from people are
happy patients all these things are nice
but it's not always easy to find those
things so you have to be your own
detective i think in a lot of ways
why did you get into this so the reason
why i decided to become a plastic
surgeon was it happened to me in grade
school
so when i was in grade school there was
a girl in my class who had a cleft lip
and palette deformity
and she was on my bus room and kids
would torture her
it was unfortunate but especially back
then because you know now we're very
focused on anti-bullying and like you
can't get away with the behavior that
used to happen when i was a kid
but people would throw things at her and
they would you know alter
you know nobody would go near her they
would you know it was because she had a
facial disfigurement unfortunately
and i was her friend i used to sit on
the bus with her
and the thing is that she had surgery
during the time that i knew her and as
her appearance started to morph and
become more normalized
people started to respond to her
differently
and i thought that was a very powerful
thing
that's the reason why plastic surgeon
wow that okay so that
um
because i think of who my dad is i've
done a lot of reading about different
personality types and what kind of
people become surgeons or ceos and
generally speaking from what i've read
it it's very disagreeable people who are
low in compassion who become surgeons
and really go up to the higher levels of
businesses
there's a higher percentage it's not
that that's the majority of us
but like the thing is is like for
example you know the rate of sociopathy
you know people who are sociopaths who
are people who are stock brokers you
know physicians politicians
surgeons specifically is much higher
than the average person out there but it
doesn't mean it's the majority of people
who go into that profession you know
what i mean so it's a little bit skewed
but it's definitely
you know
you know
hundreds of percentages more than the
average person who has a
job that's outside of that field you
know what i mean
but there are a lot of students who are
very compassionate but the thing is is
that there's a lot of physicians who
need that more aggressive
personality type if you will as surgeons
you know physicians in general not
necessarily but people who are drawn to
these kinds of fields and plastic
surgery orthopedic surgery things like
that tend to be more like that